this is not a liberal versus
conservative debate
this is a human debate this guy
helped america for both
country philistines
[Music]
he tried to punch
[Music]
[Applause]
how are you guys doing now we're going
to be talking about a very important
topic
very very very important i cannot stress
the importance
but let's first go ahead and kick it off
i'm going to ask you guys what do you
think this man is saying i'm people at
work for the scene
what he got angry
this guy from philistine this guy helped
america for both country philistines
see nas he almost got attacked by
this man and it seemed like the man
was trying to communicate something but
he didn't
he wasn't able to communicate because he
didn't speak proper english
but let's listen to it let's see if we
can decipher what this man is trying to
tell
nasp and now it's about you by now you
know if you've been watching the show
we've done a program
about him before he's from israel
palestine and the united states
the brother who went to harvard he's
born in a muslim family
his mother's practicing the day starts
at 5am with a quick pray
they sent him off to harvard lost his
dean
so out of the love we sent him a message
trying to bring him back to the dean
it didn't seem like from our
investigation that he was that well
grounded in the dean you can watch those
videos we'll
leave a link to those where we reach out
to nas
so now him being of palestinian descent
i'm from israel
palestine and the united states he calls
himself an israeli too
he has a big platform he should be able
to do some really great work creating
some
awareness of what's going on with the
innocent children that are being blown
to pieces
in this part of the world so now he runs
into someone and
the guy's about to knock him out let's
hear what this man has to say to nas
and let's see if we could decipher this
this guy hollow
america for both country philistines
[Music]
seemed like he's saying if i'm not wrong
correct me this man
this man help america for about now if
you take for about forgot me for about
philistine it seems like he's
communicating to him you forgot about
palestine he forgot about philistine you
forgot about where you're from your
roots
you forgot about it let's let's do it
one more time all right
i don't want to get this wrong this guy
hold up america for both
this guy this guy help there's a bunch
of question marks there help
america america now this is the key word
for
bout for both
[Music]
forgot philistine he forgot philistine
it's not a long stretch
so let's do it one more time this guy
hold up america for both
country philistines
[Music]
okay so either way we want to give
nas daily again out of the love he's got
a big platform
and we want his brother inshallah one
first and foremost to come back to the
dean we invite him to the dean's show he
replied one time to our video that we
did with our brother muhammad hijab he
replied to that
and maybe inshallah he'll accept this
invitation one we want to give him some
self-defense lessons so he could
defend himself because he was pretty
scared
[Music]
he tried to punch me so if something
happens like this
because i'm sure there's going to be a
lot of people who are upset upset that
he's not taking a bolder more courageous
stance
of just using his platform to help
educate people
educate people on what's going on in the
area of the world where he's from that's
the ironic thing he's from there he
should have more of a zeal he should
have more of a passion to want to
educate to bring to the light to the
forefront
what the kind of oppression what the
palestinians
with the people christians who are
palestinian muslims who are palestinians
the palestinian people are the kind of
injustices they're going through and as
he said himself now
before this is not a debate about
liberal conservative
jew christian this is about being
pro-truth
this is not a liberal versus
conservative debate
this is a human debate because he has
traveled the world and he has seen the
plight
of the different oppressed people i've
seen the boats
refugees come in i've seen the thousands
and thousands of life vests they had to
use
he's highlighted some of these things
i've seen the camps
they live in i've seen the family they
lost
but what about the oppressed people in
this part of the world
in philistine in palestine so we can get
to the bottom
of what it's really all about now now
nas maybe you're really scared maybe you
have a lot of jewish friends which you
do probably
went to harvard made a lot of jewish
friends that's not a problem because
there are
jews there are many jews and one in
particular
who was a survivor of the holocaust
who's speaking out like
many are you can use this this is a
perfect candidate that you can go ahead
and interview and just let him
use your pr platform to go ahead and
speak some of these truths
and who is this holocaust survivor this
jewish man who's speaking the truth
you know my history i don't have to
repeat it but i'm a i'm personally a
holocaust survivor
as an infant i barely survived
my my veterans were killed in auschwitz
dr gabor mate you can let dr gabor talk
about
about when he visited the occupied
territories what made him cry why did he
cry
i cried every day for two weeks and what
i saw
the brutality the occupation the petty
harassment
the murderousness of it let him talk
about
the burning down of the palestinian
or cutting down of palestinian olive
groves the denial of water rights
the humiliations nas
take for example from dr kabor the
holocaust survivor
who talks about the open air prism and
the other injustices
that made him cry people packed into
this horrible
people called the world's largest
outdoor prison which is what it is again
this is a human thing it's not a jewish
muslim arab palestinian thing this is a
human thing and look at this holocaust
survivor where he talks about the
blockade
there's no food there's no water you can
make a great documentary on this
of food of medical supplies
of sufficient water i could go on and on
and on and on
this one term i found very very
disturbing
and interesting at the same time this
term
mowing the lawn israel mows the lawn
that's the expression they use you know
what they call it
they call it mowing the lawn by which
they mean the mass
murder of palestinian civilians imagine
what you can do with that term
mowing the lawn nas many people bring up
hummus hamas whatever you call it
look how he breaks it down this
holocaust survivor because i know nash
you're probably scared like people are
going to think you're supporting
a group like this but let him just bring
him out he can go ahead and talk about
it when it comes to the death of
innocent civilians
israel killed 20 000 lebanese civilians
in 1982
using illegal weapons like cluster bombs
in a war
that ignores the justification
whatsoever
i could go on and on and on and on just
bring him out he can go ahead and talk
about it that you think the worst thing
you can say about hamas
multiplied by a thousand times
and it still will not meet the israeli
repression
and killing and dispossession of
palestinians
now instead of talking about bitcoin nas
putting that on a top priority
look at the children of palestine what's
happening to them
look at the oppression that the people
are going through
now i know you're human you got a heart
but you're probably scared of the label
that's going to be thrown at you
the label let this holocaust survivor
this jewish man talk about this label
also nas
jews who oppose israel are not jews
is a slander and for him to say
that anybody who criticized israel is an
anti-semite
is simply an egregious attempt to
intimidate
good non-jews who are willing to stand
up for what is true
and as for the final argument that
israel is subjected to
standards that other people are not it's
the other way around
nasa dr gabor mate he can talk about the
double standards nas
in myanmar the demonstrators throw
slingshots of the army at the oppressive
army
they considered to be heroes in the
western press when palestinian kids
through stones at the israeli soldiers
they're called terrorists
and israel gets away with a lot more
without much less criticism
in the western press than any other
country oh let them talk about something
that's so powerful
his invitation of people coming just to
see for
themselves i just wish your zionist
friend
would visit the occupied territories in
gaza like i have
and let him speak the way he speaks now
he's got any ounce of humanity left
he would cry like i did for two weeks
when i was there
just recommend him or let him recommend
the people that he recommends nas
anybody can listen to norman
frankenstein a jewish professor
world expert on gaza who was
denied tenure at his university because
of his public
speaking against israeli policy dr ward
talks about
people from the the army the pilots
and so many people who have protested
this eternally let him talk about that
nas you could talk to him about this
you can listen to any number of in uh
israeli defense forces soldiers
who talk about the brutality that they
now regret having committed
you can listen to israeli pilots who
talk about
why they refuse to fly over gaza
because of the atrocities they're made
to commit let him
unravel the mystery behind this the
confusion where he says it's straight
forward it's pretty straightforward
there was a land with the people living
there
and other people wanted it they took it
over
and they continued to take it over and
they continue to
to discriminate against oppress
and dispossess that other people
that's what happened and that's what's
happening let them tell the world nas
what it's all about you got a big
platform you can do a big part in us and
there's a lot of good people in israel
who feel exactly the same way that i do
so it's not a question of being poor
palestinian
it's a question of are you are in favor
of justice and and and
liberty and and and and freedom and and
and truth or are you not that's all we
had to say now it's giving you some love
again
some advice and hopefully you can come
out we got an invitation for you to come
on to the dean show so we can discuss
this
because sometimes it just needs a friend
that needs a loved one it needs someone
who cares to go ahead and share
and that's what we did to motivate the
good that's inside somebody so they can
get motivated
and they can go ahead and break through
the shackles of fear
and it's not about arab christian
jew muslim it's about being pro-truth
so let's get the truth out there nas
let's do your part
so just to recap you got the
self-defense lessons that i've offered
you
come come come so if you're ever in that
predicament again
we're going to equip you because that's
my specialty that's what i do i teach
the most effective martial art in the
world
gracie brazilian jiu jitsu so come
visit me and at the same time inshaallah
we can have you on the dean show
and we can go ahead and get you
motivated to go ahead
and get this truth out to be pro-truth
and inshallah bring you back to the help
with allah god almighty's help
bring you back so you can be with your
mother inshallah
praying together i'm sure she loved that
until next time
subscribe if you haven't already
everybody hit that
notification bell spread this far and
wide and help get this message
to our friends peace be with you
assalamu alaikum